There’s always an issue
happening right now in today’s headlines
that links back to the histories
we work on at the GLC.
So what I like to say to people is,
what are you interested in?
What’s the problem
you want to solve out there?
We might know some history
that can help you get there.
I’m currently wrapped up in a project
President Salovey asked me
to direct and manage and write,
and that is the history of
Yale University with slavery and abolition.
Yale, as everyone knows,
is about 320 years old now.
It’s a very long history,
and I have led a team, a small team
of both faculty and students
and librarians who have been crucial to this,
to research Yale’s entanglements
with the problem of slavery over time.
And we made a decision
very early in this project
not to write a report per se,
which is what most universities have done,
but to write a real narrative history.
At the GLC, we have managed and organized
a whole array of webinars, panels, events
for the Yale Project over the past two years.
We’ve done panels with the descendants
of some of the earliest black Yale students.
We’ve done panels with
local New Haven community leaders.
We did panels with undergraduates
to know what they thought.
We’ve done panels on the history
of eugenics at Yale.
So by managing that project, it gave us
another whole set of issues
to do all kinds of outreach about,
because that’s what we’re here for.
We’re a center for the study
of slavery and abolition.
But it’s remarkable sometimes
how infinite it feels when you
start thinking about all the issues
that connect to us, that connect to
the questions at the core of our mission:
How can we work on
this aspect of social justice?
How might we work on
that aspect of repairing the past
to the extent we can?
How might we work on
that policy question
by doing more history beneath it?
How should universities
look at their own past
and the past around them
that they helped create?